maintenant nous allons parler de théâtre
le théâtre avec jean pierre vincent qui
est notre invité mais avant de dialoguer
avec lui avec france n'est ce pas nous
allons voir un extrait de sina cette
pièce de corneille qui est donnée en ce
moment aux français dont jean pierre
vincent est le nouveau patron avec dans
le rôle-titre quelqu'un vous connaissez
bien parce qu'il a fait beaucoup de
télévision il faut savoir tout facilité
à temps qui s'appelle michel vitol
rose ciel tout cornaille mêmes
tousignant ne tient évidemment pas dans
cette seule apostrophe mais à beaucoup
d'entre nous la célèbre réplique servira
de point de repère pour évoquer une
passionnante tragédie dont l'actualité
humaines et politiques restent
terriblement intacte on avait peut-être
oublié depuis les bancs du lycée que
corneille pouvait être si moderne toute
la force de michel witold et de nous le
rappeler superbement ce ne serait ce que
dans le sentiment de déchirures de
l'être ainsi à travers un grand comédien
un grand texte se redécouvre subversif
point c'est puissant bien plus ce même
jour je te tends emilie d'ignobles chez
tes voeux de toute l'italie est commise
sur mon amour et mes soins quand
couronneau je t'aurais aimé voir tu t'en
souviens sinon
tant d'heures et tant de gloire ne
peuvent pas si tôt sortir de ta mémoire
est ce qu'on ne pourrait jamais
s'imaginer seen as tu t'en souviens et
je veut m'assassiner pour un seigneur
mois que juste une âme si traîtresse
tient mal ta promesse iec toi je n'ai
pas dit encore ce que je veux tu te
justifiera après si tu le peux